elle était pas mal celle là comment
allez-vous moi ça va très bien oui je
suis l'homme qui en a rien à [ __ ]
aujourd'hui à faire une vidéo réaction
facile à faire mais elle me tient
vraiment à coeur parce que j'ai
découvert un nouveau délire un truc qui
me fait plus rire la vidéo de baptiste
qui fait un feu dans sa chambre qu'il
pense a battu vient pas longtemps je me
baladais sur twitter comme tous les
jours quand j'adore perdre trois heures
à rien faire sur internet et je suis
tombé sur ça voici mon fils
incroyable non hu au sein goku comme il
est mignon dit bonjour saint goin
bonjour tout le monde
bonjour de monde c'est mickey quoi c'est
un extrait du sol doublage québécois qui
a été fait pour dbz je crois il ya
vraiment une très faible proportion des
mécènes qui a été un doublé en québécois
ensuite il y diffuser la balle à la vf
il faut savoir que le doublage des fois
c'est compliqué ok donc c'est des boîtes
qui cherchent de ça ils reçoivent les
textes en vo et doivent les traduire et
parmi ce qu'ils doivent traduire il ya
des blagues mais des blagues qui marche
par exemple aux états unis qui vont
faire marrer les américains mais qui ne
nous font pas nous faire rire parce
qu'on comprend pas le délire donc ils
doivent adapter sa dans notre langue
des fois il se creuse un peu la tête et
il arrive à faire un truc drôle tu vas
faire marrer le pays en question mais
des fois il n'arrive pas du tout on va
en voir tout à l'heure des adaptations
nul mais cela d adaptation fidèle ou
juste le doublage les voix collent pas
du tout aux persos koala par exemple
c'est terrible kouagou coup on dirait ma
cas d'erreur nov
incroyable non commençons par terminer
cette vidéo là qui est l'une des
meilleures il veut juste te saluer 100
go 100 go ans et demi et dix ans gore
génial regarde quelque chose fonce droit
sur nous non tu aimais sur la planète
veut jeta à sur la planète veut jeta
ckoi zep la même mais on la connaît pas
et un nouvel arc de dbz qui est secret
césar et quelque chose d'inattendu se
produisit qui sont ils pas le colossal
seyant connu sous le nom de napa
affronte à saintes beaucoup en premier
le voici
ou comme j'ai peur
[Rires]
le mec fait 100 fois la taille de
beaucoup et lui ont donné la voix de
t'choupi c'est incroyable c'était
maintenant au tour de veuze tard le
prince de toul essayant montre peu de
quoi tuer fait qu à carreaux puissance
quelques heures
y'a pas les ja pas les bruitages en fait
je crois que dans le point rare qu'ils
ont reçues il n'y avait pas le dossier
bruitages ils ont oublié de le mettre au
japon du coup c'est terrible quoi c'est
un combat ya pas bruitages mais non
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
wj tu donc je suis l'espoir de l'univers
je suis la réponse à tout laissait il
utilise non sans déconner il utilise les
codes les codes de montage qui font
marrer dans les vagues n'est tout c'est
le genre nanana salue le fait de couper
la musique au moment où le gars dit la
blague mais où ils le font alors qu'il
erre de guibert sérieux faut pas faire
ça je te ferai payer tout le maloya
arrêtez de couper la musique ça c'est
vraiment le haut que tu fais souvent
toilettes soit au lire mais ya pas de
c'est pas la joie ça hein c'est
l'orgasme
voilà il est très amoureux de freezer
c'est ainsi que le garçon connu sous le
nom de san goku continua de grandir en
vf
quelqu'un nous avoir un extrait de x-men
92 en vf à l'oeil c'est sûr c'était
après la pause du midi il soit allée au
japonais le serveur [ __ ] leur a proposé
un petit sac et pour digérer ça a mal
tourné a oui j'ai vu batman passé
j'avais vu je crois que c'était un
patrick guillotin qui doublées batman et
c'est aussi le mec qui double dans les
simpsons mère j'ai oublié le nom mais
enfin non j'ai pas limité pascal hennuy
faire du scandale à main j'ai oublié son
nom mais bref il doubla perso des
simpson et il faut aussi des voix dans
les jeunes et une canette de bière ça
serait autant de bruit contre un opéra
temps bref double des persos vraiment
cartonné un peu pas idiot mais bon voilà
second degré et là il se retrouve à
doubler un super héros donc tu te doutes
bien qu'on y avoir un problème
le installer mes pieds ceux qui
pénètrent dans le temple de cuba
la voix ni méchants et bien les mecs je
veux que tous les héros des films marvel
à venir au cinéma là avec les budgets de
plusieurs centaines de millions soit
doublée par cet homme patrick tu es
notre héros le macd est juste qui se
basent au cas où le spectateur n'a pas
compris qui tombait et lyon voire
l'ordinateur fonctionne comme vous savez
comment c'est artistique il a pas
d'italien on a merdé ce un super héros
et là tout à l'air ridicule ya un
problème
en plus ce qui est terrible c'est que
superman y est bien doublé honda oman
zavala voix fallait bien le voit du
méchant et bien y'a vraiment que la voix
de batman qu'il va pas du tout donc ça
qu'on trace de ouf
quelques minutes plus tard il arrive
jusqu'à les frais ce haut niveau et
batman est allé à ok je retiens ce qu
ils ont fait tous des bills oh [ __ ] je
prends ma désole toute la journée alors
à ya aussi ken le survivant qui avait
des problèmes mais je crois de
d'adaptation s'était pas doublage qui
était mauvais ou qui collait pas aux
personnes c'était juste la traduction
des textes qui était fait vraiment sans
effort il va utiliser la technique
secret du au couteau de cuisine
j'espère qu'il sait ce qu'est dieu aux
côtes de djezzy est l'essence même de
l'école coutadeur le frapper son
adversaire
il faut que les jumeaux avec au couteau
20 ch
ak utero et vu qu'à couteau il faut
couteau burke de cuisine forces de
l'ordre depuis attaques de la grande
ourse et d'une puissance incalculables
moi même j'ai des difficultés pour le
calcul
le roi du hokuto trezeguet jeu très
bientôt le seul et unique détenteur du
savoir au couteau à lui à les oiseaux de
feu de l'école mentaux ce sont des
disciples particuliers qui ont reçu un
entraînement spécial il parle vraiment
qu'un star documentaires animaliers
incroyable earth attaquons la grâce et
la rapidité de l'oiseau de feu leur
pouvoir d'une force d'une cruauté sans
égard sans égards après attention il
faut pas les blâmer c'était complète pas
une autre époque c'est dans les années
90 la culture nippon n'avait pas encore
marqué la france comme c'est le cas
actuellement et c'était surtout destiné
pour les enfants non qui censure est
vachement est il adapté de manière un
peu rigolo mais pour les enfants mais tu
regardes ça maintenant c'est génial
c'est du bonheur vous trouvez un jaguar
force
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
une scène dramatique en plus ancien
centriste up était quand même ouvrir la
bouche ça va être je hais les jeunes ont
le mot
j'aurais voulu que nous fûmes après el
mestiri mais non mes mecs c'est chaud et
pourquoi
mais oui pourquoi
arrêtes tu vas faire pleurer et
paiements p2p
wahou [ __ ] trop d'émotion je vais
pleurer bordel alors à le doublage
français des années 90 les meilleurs à
jamais mais oui exactement
oui dépêche toi je suis vraiment pressé
dis moi ce que tu veux me proposer je
vois que tu as toujours aussi mauvais
caractère ma méthode a chip et
connaissant sa réputation je pense que
tu gravira big tous les âges sont alors
tous les âges choix c'était vraiment une
autre époque c'est ouf à nous avoir un
doublage nul bonjour je suis devant un
stylo d'orangi qua non de nous appeler
mon psy je vais continuer à lire telle
vous plaît mais c'est le pirate mais je
le doublais bien sept mois toquer chez
lui mon coeur continue à lire s'il vous
plaît monsieur le pirate
le japon va défendre dans cette vidéo le
pire ce pas mon ouvrage ok c'est ma
coupe de cheveux et que je te plutôt
kureishi calculer ces [ __ ] il a pas
de voix c'est génial merci pour ce
dialogue
incroyable il m'a fait beaucoup de bien
oui du jojo's bizarre adventure alors
attends attends je m'appelle jean pierre
palmarès c'est ce que je me disais au
début quand ils doivent adapter des
blagues dans notre langue je pense que
là par exemple en fait partie oui tous
les pays pauvres
ils sont des punchline mon gars
incroyable alors faut pas faire faire
aux autres ce que tu as la trouille de
faire tout seul c'est dingue ça n'a
vraiment pas de race
le doublage génial c'est un best-of des
trucs les plus cools en fait du doublage
là il n'est pas du tout raté
avec un rêve je suis dans le bac sont
d'accord un long backs avec un rêve
c'est vous que nous voulons aller si
vous êtes toi je alors à la hauteur je
m'appelle ratchet je crois qu'il est
appelé clan l'oubli est dans le coup
mais arrêtez de me vanner en plus aux
vans aimé le film il a très bien marché
[Musique]
en tout cas c'était une hyper bonne
expérience j'ai adoré faire ça à
l'époque c'était trop cool et après
libre aux gens de trouver que le
doublage est bien ou pas mais c'est une
bonne expérience mais j'ai clairement
pas un millième du talent de tout ce
qu'on vient de voir la aux [ __ ] ça
que j'avais fait une vidéo il ya cinq
ans où je au nom ça va être non bon fils
sur ça on fait tout ça parce qu'après je
jouerai pas le courage de faire le trou
j'avais fait une vidéo je faisais tous
les bruits du trailer de mw3 mais avec
ma bouche voilà déjà l'idée vous fait
pas qu'y fait faisable et de partir mais
bientôt vous verrez que chaque jour
chaque mois
destiné jeu c'est une cache du cortex
devant les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo sur le doublage pas si vous a plu
ces gars n'étaient pas élevées que
d'habitude un immense respect aux
doubleurs français parce qu'ils sont
vraiment très très bon on a des voix
incroyable je pense à patrick poivey à
christophe le mois parmi tant d'autres
xaintrailles de malades et même si les
français se plaignent très souvent des
vf même dans les jeux on a vraiment des
vrais talents qu à des gens très doués
qui font ça et je comprends qu'on puisse
préférer la vo parce que bahdja c'est la
voix de l'acteur quand on parle de film
ou de téléfilms ou de séries forcément
tu te rends bien compte du jeu d'acteur
quand c'est en vo que quand ça en vf
mais pour tout ce qui est dessins animés
ou films d'animation quoi je trouve
vraiment confiance on a des très bons
douleur et dans ces cas là je trouve ça
dommage et faire une fixette sur la vo
alors que les vf sont très très bonnes
bon sauf qu'on squeeze double perso
principal mais sinon c'est vrai une
petite dernière la comme ça sur exemple
passer un bon moment à trouver de cette
prochaine vidéo
[Musique]
c'est tout c'est tout
ça